the Joe Rogan experience I think Mark
Cuban could do a good job I think he'd
like to be president agree I probably
vote he's more of a libertarian you know
he's been real mark you know I love you
he's been real [ __ ] about this Cove
it's tough is it I don't think the MBA
should be back yeah recently yeah I
think his mom's like nine hundred years
old so it's worried she's gonna get it
Wow hi dude put her in a bubble dude
it's like the same it's like that
Hollywood actor that that Indian guy
who's in the Marvel movie who's just
preaching from the mountains
who's that like we're gonna open up and
she can get worse we should shut down
Kumail Nanjiani that guy shut the [ __ ]
up dude make another Marvel movie he's
just saying cuz his wife has an
underlying condition so he's worried
about that which I get dude from a
personal standpoint I get that but also
read the stats you're smart he's super
smart you're smart dude man there's that
but there's also a little bit of virtru
signaling where people are saying things
that they know that the enlightened
thoughtful people are supposed to say
and then they get support online to
check the tweets all of those people
agree with me yeah look I did I got them
to like me more hope I'm in [ __ ]
spider-man nine thank you for saying
this you're amazing God every life
matters if we like met everyone has to
say that every life matters yeah well
where were you before this kovat thing
cuz people are dying all the time it's
interesting to see that this that
obesity is the number one factor in
people in New York City because all
these people that want to think that
it's okay to be obese it's fine yeah if
that's not cute man now is it not cute
it's like really bad for you yeah dude
yet we've known this yeah for any Kovach
comes goes oh this is too easy
and then if this doesn't scare your fat
ass in the [ __ ] you think the people
like with all this fat shaming mentality
out there that people will that the
government or someone the public health
will step up and have some sort of a
public health campaign saying look folks
you've gotta lose weight you got to stop
eating sugar it's terrible for your
immune system get yourself down to
reasonable size so we'd love to see that
and see what to the people freaked out
about it and all the people that try to
counter it with emotions and [ __ ]
it's alright to have tits
stop trying to define beauty standards
muffin tops are cool yeah I don't know
what you're gonna do man I saw a video I
don't know why selves I saw a video
I think named Josh washer is a video of
kids in the 70s and in gym class just a
random gym class these kids were all in
[ __ ] phenomenal shape there's like a
hundred kids everyone slim everyone slim
that's how it should be man I know I'm a
little thick but I'm in shape dude my
heart's great my resting heart rates
insane but these kids were all in shape
man all these kids you go to high school
now every kid gets a letter from his mom
he can't work out because of you know
Billy hats or ankles Billy Billy gets
anxiety when you make him run a mile
what the [ __ ] I have to run a mile
yes Billy is anxious bilious anxious he
doesn't respond well to pressure leave
him alone leave them alone
one thing that we saw from this is that
there's so many people that don't know
how to deal with any sort of diversity I
can't be their friend I haven't I have
people who I used to talk to and when
this thing came out and we're she's
gonna bunker down and I think the
economy stores to me closer 2022 and
we're not gonna be on the road a moment
who I'm not gonna tell you saving money
nope that can't and when they rhyme with
was the name's Ryan we're not gonna do
it I'll tell you afterwards okay I
learned what ah we can't be friends
anymore
oh wow you can't be my foxhole dude this
scared you all this ain't [ __ ] Bubba
well we can't be friends anymore I don't
I learned don't talk I'm anxious to talk
to Michael you on Monday the way he was
describing it like I just be cool
Michael be cool man you got through it
bro he's gonna scare the [ __ ] out of
everybody he thought he was gonna die
but he got pneumonia but here's the
thing
pneumonia is still real people still get
pneumonia people die from it if you get
pneumonia and that I got pneumonia when
I was 19
yeah if you get into my son got
pneumonia - and that you're [ __ ]
tonight what happened with them but you
still survived
don't come on here and [ __ ] skate
Michael yo I will [ __ ] you up don't come
on here and scare everybody dude we
happy we get enough man you ever watch
CNN
and you would think the world's on fire
what's that guy's name brian Stelter
he's my favorite he's a chubby guy he's
like the Balder chubby guy he's rarely
on there very feminine s'more lemon
yeah but I love when he gets when he's
all doom and gloom oh god it's just
Tim Dylan tweeted this last night this
is interesting ID so Bryce off from
butts on Newsweek was Crone virus
survivors permanently disqualified from
joining us military recruitment memo
suggests
[Applause]